WE WILL TRY THIS AGAIN. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL AT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING. AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE TODAY IN
THE CAPITAL. I ASKED ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THE PRESIDENT
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
BEGAN OUR HEARING TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANTS COLD NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
FOUR ONE. ONE ONE FOUR ZERO.
THAT'S. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOWTHE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TWO
THOUSAND ZERO DOT ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR OPERATOR TO ASSIGN
YOUR LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTE IT AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID ACOUSTIC ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL TRY TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
THE SHERIN S. CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. BUT TODAY WE
HAVE FIVE BILLS ON OUR AGENDA-
S. B. NINE OH THREE IS ON
CONSENT BUT BEFORE WE ARE HERE
OUR FIRST PRESENTATION WE NEED
TO STOP THEIR QUORUM WERE
ANNOUNCER CONSULTANT CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. BRADFORD YOUR
BRADFORD HERE A CHAU VOGUE HERE
TROUBLE HERE CALM WATER. SKINNER
WIENER. WIENER HERE TO QUORUM
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
JOHN NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR AND NOT SENATOR
MANNY AS S. B. EIGHT SIX THREE
CENTER MAN WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN AND FUTURE READ FOR
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL. SB
EIGHT SIXTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH REVIEW
TEAMS TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF
THEIR INVESTIGATIONS AND
REPORTING TO ALSO EXAMINE NEAR
DEATH INCIDENTS RESULTING FROM
DOMESTIC ABUSE. ANY ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE WORK OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH REVIEW
TEAM SO LET ME JUST BRIEFLY GO
OVER WHAT THEY DO THEY- PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN CREATING
RESEARCH ON DOMESTIC ABUSE
RELATED FATALITIES. WITH THE
CENTRAL GOAL OF IDENTIFYING GAPS
IN THE SYSTEM AND TRYING TO
PREVENT FUTURE TRAGEDIES. THAT
ROUTINES ARE OPTIONAL FOR
COUNTIES AND ARE COMPRISED OF
VOLUNTEERS FROM LEGAL HEALTH
SERVICE ADVOCACY JUDICIAL
GROUPS. THEY WORK WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO TRY TO PROVIDE A
CONFIDENTIAL FORUM TO
SYSTEMATICALLY REVIEW DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RELATED DEATHS. I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THEY DO NOT CHANGE
THE LAW- AND SO CONTRARY TO I
THINK SOME OF THE CRITICS THAT
WE RECEIVED ON THIS BILL THEY
ARE PURELY ADVISORY BODY. AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE BENEFICIAL ROLE
THAT THESE TEAMS PLAY THE ORANGE
COUNTY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH
REVIEW TEAM. RECENTLY REPORT
PRODUCED A REPORT CONTAINING
DATA AND RECOMMENDATIONS
STEMMING FROM TEN YEARS WORTH OF
RESEARCH. THIS CRITICAL REPORT
SHED LIGHT ON MANY ISSUES IN MY
COMMUNITY SPECIFICALLY
ILLUSTRATING SOME OF THE
TRIGGERS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATHS SOME OF THE PATTERNS THAT
ABUSE CAN FOLLOW. WHAT WARNING
SIGNS TO LOOK OUT FOR AND MORE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY LIMITS THESE TEAMS TO
ONLY INVESTIGATE AND RESEARCH
SITUATIONS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
ABUSE THAT ACTUALLY RESULT IN
DEATH. THIS IGNORES A LARGE
NUMBER OF INCREDIBLY SERIOUS
INCIDENTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FOR THE PUSA PARTY CAME VERY
CLOSE TO BUT DID NOT ACTUALLY
SUCCEED IN KILLING THE OTHER
PARTY. COMMUNITIES AND EXPERTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT IF WE ARE
ALLOWED TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF
COVERAGE HERE SO THAT WE LISTEN
TO THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO
SURVIVED NEAR DEATH INCIDENTS.
THESE VOICES PROVIDE CRUCIAL
CONTEXT BACKGROUND INFORMATION
AND RARE INSIGHTSABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE CAN'T GATHER WHEN
WE'RE ONLY LOOKING CASES WHERE
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS DIED. ON A
NATIONWIDE LEVEL WE'RE SEEING
MANY STATES RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTIGATING NEAR
DEATH INCIDENTS AND EXPANDING
THE ROLE OF DEATH REVIEW TEAMS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOR A THIRD
OF STATE LEGISLATURES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE PASSED LAWS
AUTHORIZING DEATH REVIEW TEAMS
TO RESEARCH NEAR FATALITIES.
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING BY I'M
HERE AND NOT WE- AND ARE UPDATED
LAWS ARE HINDERING OUR- TO
CONDUCT A COMPREHENSIVE RESEARCH
THAT CAN HELP US PREVENT FUTURE
DEBTS. HAVING THIS DATA AT OUR
FINGERTIPS IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER AS WE'VE SEEN REPORTS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURGEON
LAST COUPLE YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
CAN'T AFFORD TYRONE HANDS BEHIND
OUR BACKS WHEN IT COMES TO
RESEARCHING AND UNDERSTANDING
HOW TO PREVENT DOMESTIC ABUSE
RELATED DEATHS. THIS IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW TEAMS PLAYING
PROCEEDING AND PROTECTING
SURVIVORS ADDRESS ABOUNDS SB
SIXTY THREE WOULD AUTHORIZE
TEAMS INVESTIGATE NEAR DEATH
INCIDENTS. BRING CALIFORNIA IN
ALIGNMENT WITH NUMEROUS OTHER
STATES. I WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TODAY BETHANY WEBB A
SURVIVOR OF THE SEAL BEACH SALON
SHOOTING. AND DR DAVID WELCH ONE
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH
REVIEW TEAM. THANK YOU ARE IN
FAIRNESS WILL PROVIDE FOUR
MINUTES TO EACH SIDE BOTH IN
SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION IF WE HAVE
OUR FIRST WITNESS- HERE PRESENT
HERE IN THE ROOM. SHE'S FROM THE
PHONE. I AM MODERATOR WILL YOU
ARM WITNESS MAY BEGIN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE WEBER. ON JUNE SIXTH
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN MY OLDEST
CHILD NICKY CAME HOME FROM AN
OVERNIGHT VISIT WITH HER
BIOLOGICAL FATHER. I KNOW THIS
IS NOT AN EASY PHASES BRIDGES
FALLEN YOU CAN FASTER DISTURBING
GOING ON FOR AWHILE AND HADN'T
SAID ANYTHING BECAUSE OF THAT IT
WOULD BE WAY WORSE IF I WAS
TOLD. I PROMISE THURMOND I WOULD
NEVER STAND NIKKI BACK AGAIN
HOWEVER THE BIOLOGICAL FATHER
BEGAN PETITIONING WITHIN WEEKS
FOR REUNIFICATION AND. THE COURT
WAS WORKING TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
I THE OTHER HOW MUCH TO RUN AWAY
MY JOB IN ORDER TO PROTECT
MAKING. I'M NOT CHANGING MY
SISTER LARA. WORKER MICHELLE AT
THE SALON THERE ARE CHARGES
BEACH WAS ALSO GOING TO A CHILD
CUSTODY COURT. SHE HAD BEEN WE
HAD BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
SIMILARITIES IN OUR CASES. SHE
HAD A FIVE YEAR RESTRAINING
ORDER THAT WAS RESCINDED IN
EARLY TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. ON
OCTOBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN MICHELIN HER ACTUALLY
GETTING FIFTY FIFTY CUSTODY THIS
WAS NOT ENOUGH. ON OCTOBER
TWELFTH HE WALKED INTO SALON
MARRIAGE JOSH BONTA THREE GUN
AND A BULLET PROOF VEST. HE WENT
STRAIGHT TO MICHELLE AND SAID
THIS IS WHAT YOU WANTED. AND
STARTED. MICHELLE AND THEN THE
NEXT TWO MINUTES HE SHOT A TOTAL
OF NINE PEOPLE EIGHT OF THEM
DIED INCLUDING MY SISTER LARA
AND MICHELLE MY MOM WAS THE ONLY
PERSON THAT DAY THAT WAS SHOT
AND SURVIVED SHE WAS THERE
GETTING HER NAILS DONE. IT WAS
BACK IN COURT FIVE DAYS LATER ON
OCTOBER SEVENTH AND AGAIN ON
DECEMBER THIRD TWO. BIOLOGICAL
FATHER BECAME SO AGGRESSIVE THAT
I WAS GIVEN A FIVE YEAR
RESTRAINING ORDER. I'M HERE TO
TELL MY SIDE OF THE STORY.
MICHELLE LET'S NOT AND HOW MUCH
MORE COULD WE LEARN IF SHE WAS.
YEAH YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ON THE LINE. THE TERM ONLY
WOULDN'T SO NOW WE HAVE DOCTOR
DAVID WELCH- ONE OF MEMBERS
ORANGE COUNTY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AT THREE EIGHTEEN I THINK YOU
SOMEONE. DR WELCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOUR HONOR. MY NAME IS
THAT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. MY
NAME IS DR DAVID WELLS I'M A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST LICENSE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE BEEN DOING BATTERS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM GROUPS FOR
MEN AND WOMEN OFFENDERS. IN
ORANGE COUNTY FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF WELL
MORE PSYCHOLOGY GROUP. AND HAVE
BEEN ON THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW TEAM COMING UP TO
FIFTEEN YEARS. CURRENTLY WE ARE
ONLY ALLOWED TO EXAMINE
FATALITIES ARE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW TEAM RELIED ON
CORONER'S OFFICE RECORDS POLICE
REPORT AND DATABASE SEARCHES.
WE'VE OFTEN FOUND THAT'S VERY
LIMITING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HISTORY LEADING UP TO THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOMICIDES AND
ESPECIALLY HOMICIDE SUICIDE.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO REMAINING
PERPETRATOR INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION. INSTEAD THE
CALORIES RECORDS ARE FOCUSED ON
THE DETECTION OF THE CAUSE OF
DEATH NOT BACKGROUND DYNAMICS
AND HELP VICTIMS TRYING TO SEEK
. THIS BILL CREATES A VOLUNTARY
OPTION FOR TEAMS TO REVIEW NEAR
FATAL CASES AND ANY SURVIVORS
AND PUT THEM VOLUNTARY. THE BILL
PROVIDES CONFIDENTIALITY AND
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA CAN JOIN OTHER STATES
AND ALLOWING DOMESTIC. VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW CHANGE TO LEARN
FROM NEAR FATAL ABUSES. WE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE
UNABLE TO BENEFIT FROM ONE OF
THE GREATEST RESOURCES IN OUR-
I'M JAIL. AND FATAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE VOICES AND
EXPERIENCES OF SURVIVORS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FOUR FIFTEEN OTHER
STATES HAVE PASSED STATUTE
ALLOWING NEAR DEATH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASE EXAMINATION AND
30% OF THE STATES NOW PERMIT
REVIEW OF NEAR DEATH. NOTABLY
ZERO LEGISLATORS ACROSS THE
COUNTY VOTED AGAINST EXPANDING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH REVIEW
TEAMS TO INCLUDE NAR DEATH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW
WILL MOVE TO FORTY TWO ALL THREE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
FORTY THREE OLD. THREE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF S. B.
EIGHT SIX THREE AND SUPPORT.
HEARINGS THREE NINE NOW WILL GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM. SURE
ANYONE THERE AND OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. I GUESS
NOT. NO ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES- MODERATOR THERE
ANYONE CALLERS IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SIX THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE YOU NEED TO PICK
IT UP BEFORE YOU PRESS THE
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS IN
SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT SIXTY THREE
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN. FINAL
PAYMENTS- DETACHMENT FROM BEHALF
OF THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. Q. NEXT
CALL. THANK YOU TO BE JUST ONE
SECOND HERE WHILE WE GET THE
LINE NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY THREE THAT IS ONE
ONE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. GETTING
A LINE NUMBER HERE'S IT'LL BE
JUST A SECOND. BARRETT. BY
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS CRYSTAL ON BEHALF
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN Q. IN SUPPORT. OKAY
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIX
THREE. ON THE LINE AS LEAD
OPPOSITION I SEE NON LISTED. I
SEE NO ONE COMING FORWARD HERE
IN THIS ROOM. MODERATOR CAN WE
GO TO PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF S. B.
EIGHT SIX THREE. AND DOMINATED
ONE BANK THERE- IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
THREE. ONE VENDOR ZERO
OPPOSITION. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY GEARING UP RIGHT NOW.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEES OR ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS ROGER. PARENTS
ARE QUE THE- BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR WINNER. MAY WE CALL
THE ROLE WE HAVE A TO PASS- FOR
THE FIRST YEAR JUDICIARY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. B. EIGHT SIX THREE SB
EIGHT SIX THREE DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD
AYE ACCIONES. DROBO GUY CAMARGO
I LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE IT'S FIVE
ZERO THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
IT IS OUT OF COMMITTEE BEFORE WE
TAKE YOUR NEXT BILL LET'S GET A
MOTION ARE CONCERNED CALENDAR WE
HAVE- S. B. NINE ZERO THREE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS OUR MOTION
FOR THE CONCERN CALAR. SO MODES
ONE MODE CAN WE CALL THE ROLL ON
A CONSENT ITEM. SB NINE OH THREE
IT'S THE CONSENT CALENDAR%
BRADFORD REDFORD I'D SHOW BOGUE
I TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER. AND
LONGER AYE SKINNER SKINNER I
WINNER WINNER RIGHTS FIVE ZERO
INSTANT CALENDARS OUT FIVE ZERO
NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO SENATOR
MAN HE HAS S. B. NINE ONE FIVE
INTERMENT THANK YOU CHAIR
BRADFORD I'M SWITCHING GEARS
PRESENT SB NINE FIFTEEN WHICH
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE STATE. IS
NOT PROFITING FROM THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AMMUNITION AND FIREARM
PRECURSOR PARTS ON STATE
PROPERTY OR FACILITATING GUN
SHOWS THAT CAN UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA STRONG FIREARM
REGULATIONS. AS YOU'LL LIKELY
REMEMBER LAST YEAR I BROUGHT A
SIMILAR BILL TO THIS COMMITTEE-
THAT BILL DID PASS IN THE SENATE
BUT WAS NARROWED IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO FOCUS SOLELY ON ORANGE
COUNTY. BUT WE WATCH OUR LAST
YEAR THE TERRIFYING CONSEQUENCES
OF GUN SALES AND VIOLENCE AS
THEY PLAY OUT. IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
DEATHS OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF
GUN VIOLENCE NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED MASS SHOOTINGS TOOK
PLACE IN EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION GUNS WERE SOLD. I THINK
I TOLD YOU THE ORIGINS OF THIS
BILL LAST YEAR OR TWO YEARS AGO-
WHEN I WAS CAMPAIGNING FOR THE
SEAT I NOW HOLD THAT WE HAD THE
EL PASO SHOOTINGS FOLLOWED BY
THE DAYTON SHOOTINGS- THAT NEXT
MORNING. MY FAMILY AND I WERE
SCHEDULED TO RUN A FIVE K. FUN
RUN AT THIS ORANGE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS I AND AS WE CROSS
THE FINISH LINE- EVERYONE OF US
INCLUDING MY YOUNGEST WHO'S THEN
ABOUT THREE YEARS OLD- WAS
HANDED WE ARE HAND FLYERS
PROMOTING NEXT WEEKEND'S. GUN
SHOW THAT THE STATE THAT SAME
FAIRGROUNDS NOW WHEN I GREW UP-
FAIRGROUNDS ARE MEANT FOR FAMILY
FRIENDLY ACTIVITIES AND TODAY
THERE UNFORTUNATELY SYNONYMOUS
WITH GUN SHOWS- THE VIOLENT
OVERTONES OF THOSE GUN SHOWS AND
AFFECTED THEY FACILITATE THE
SALE OF MANY UNLICENSED GUNS.
AND MANY MANY MORE LICENSE GUNS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE KNOW
THE STRONG LINKAGE BETWEEN GUN
DISTRIBUTIONS AND GUN VIOLENCE
ACCORDING TO THE GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
GUN SHOWS OFTEN CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CIRCUMVENT GUN
SAFETY LAWS. THEIR COMMON. VENUE
FOR STRAW PURCHASES AND ILLEGAL
UNDER. OUR OWN- BUREAU ALCOHOL
TOBACCO IN FOR. HAS IT. GUN
SHOWS AS MAJOR TRACK CHANNEL AND
HAVE FOUND THE SALE OF ILLEGAL
UNLICENSED GUNS ACROSS THE
STATE. MOREOVER THAT IS ONLY BE
LISTED GUNS- WE OF COURSE HAVE
THE PROBLEM GOES GUNS. AND WHEN
I ATTENDED A GUN SHOW A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THE MOST POPULAR
VENDORS BY FAR WE'RE THE ONE
SELLING OF GUN. PARTS MEANT TO
BE ASSEMBLED INDICATES THESE ARE
CASH AND CARRY. THEIR CARRIED
OFF A LOT BY THEY HAVE NO SERIAL
NUMBERS ON THEM THEY'RE FAIRLY
EASY TO ASSEMBLE I AND THEY ARE
NOW UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE-
LARGEST SOURCES OF- CROCK
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY IN THE STATE.
DENTURES ARE DESIGNED FOR ONE
PURPOSE TO SELL GUNS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE AT THAT I
THINK WE HAVE TO SAY ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH. I'M WORKING CLOSELY WITH
MY COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT
VENTURA. I TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WEEKEND GUN SHOWS
ADVENTURE UP BUT ALSO TO END GUN
SHOWS ON STATE PROPERTY. AROUND
THE STATE THIS IS A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE THE STATE SHOULD NOT
BE PROFITING OFF OF THIS WE NEED
TO TAKE A STAND. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BUT- I HAVEN'T.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. KATHY LONG
A FORMER VENTURA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. AND MEMBER UP INSURE
COUNTY BRADY UNITED. AS WELL
STEVE LANGLEY. A MEMBER OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BRADY CHAPTER.
THANK YOU WILL BE ALLOW FORM FOR
EACH SIDE TO MINUTES OF. MISS
LAW OF YOUR RATE YOU MAY BE. I
AM THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU SO THEIR MEN AND SOME
OF THE RAMON FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. AS WAS MENTIONED I
WOULD BECOME A SUPERVISOR FOR
TWENTY YEARS THIRTY FIVE YEAR
RESIDENTS VENTURA COUNTY A
MOTHER AN ADVOCATE WITH VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD UNITED. AND
HUNDREDS OF SUPPORTERS IN THIS
COUNTY PULL THIS BILL WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR YEARS TO END THE
CONTRACTING OF GUN SHOWS IN OUR
PROGRAM. WHICH IS STATE OWNED
PROPERTY OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ARE CITIES THE
PENSION OXNARD BALK OR SUPPORT
AND FOR A LONG TIME SHOWS. THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION WE
FEEL IT REALLY IS A TIME TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF HOW WE
APPROACH- BOTH GUNS AND GUN
SHOWS AT THE FAIRGROUNDS FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES- ARE FAIR BOARDS NEED
TO. CONTRACTING THE GUN SHOWS
THEY ARE NOT A PROTECTED CLASS.
AND THEY SHOULDN'T BE GRANTED
THIS STATUS- COACH OF BROWN'S IN
OUR COMMUNITIES HAS MUCH CHANGE
MUST BE TREATED AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. TO CHANGE THE
PARADIGM OF HOW WE AS HUMAN
BEINGS BROADBAND SAFER
COMMUNITIES I WAS ALSO REMEMBER
JUST MENTIONED THE- ARE PROLIFIC
A NUMBER OF GUN SHOWS THAT
COUNTIES HAVE THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE. ACCESS SOMETIMES-
UNLICENSED- OF THE PROLIFERATION
OF GHOST GUNS WILL BECOME A
SIGNIFICANT- PUBLIC SAFETY
THREAT. SO TO CHANGE THE GUN
CULTURE AND TO STOP THE
ADVERTISING THAT GOES ON OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY TIME THERE'S A
GUN SHOW. ON OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN
SEE THIS ADVERTISEMENT THEY'RE
GOING TO ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS
THEIR LIVES HAVE CHANGED FOREVER
AROUND THE CULTURE OF GUN SHOWS
IN GUNS OF OUR COMMUNITY. SO I-
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
WE DO THE BREAK- COALITION AS
MANY OF- IT IS PUBLIC OWNED. WE
SHOULD STOP THEIR STOCK. WELL
DONE- MAKING FOUR PRO FOR- AND
OUR COMMUNITY UP THE BACKS OF
HOUSTON FAMILIES- SO THEN WE
STRONGLY. THIS THANK YOU FOR
MUCH FOR A PART. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS MR LOW. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND THANK YOU SENATE MEANT
SEPARATELY ON BOTH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILLIAMS I
HAVE TWENTY YEARS OF ONE FOUR
STRENGTH AND WAS A OF DEPARTMENT
OF. FIREMAN FROM 200-092-2000 I
HERE IN THE AND RIVER AND- OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY CHAPTER BRADY
THE ORANGE COUNTY CHOPPER IS A
STORE WORKING TO. CRIME INJURING
DEATH THIS CHAKRA THE NEW
MEMBERS OF WALK ALONG ONE ON BY
IN FURTHERANCE OF OUR GOAL. ARE
TO FARM BROWN ARE CAN ORANGE
COUNTY. A BRADY'S PLEASE BECAUSE
IN THE OF THE BILL NINE FIFTEEN
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE CAL ACT
THE NATION BROADER LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE RESPONSIBLE BUSINESS
PRACTICES AGAIN SHOWS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO NINETY FIVE CALIFORNIA
ALL FIREARM TRANSFERS AGAIN
SHOWS MUST BE PROCESSED THROUGH
A LICENSED FIREARM DEALER
LICENSE FARM DEALER OPPORTUNITY
CAN SHOW MUST COMPLY WITH ALL
OTHER APPLICABLE LAWS. COULD BE
CALIFORNIA'S WAITING PERIOD
CALIFORNIA LAWS GOVERNING THE
TRANSFER FIRES REVIEWERS ALL
LOCAL ORDINANCES REGULATIONS AND
FEES BY FARMERS PROTESTED
PURCHASED AT BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES FIREARMS PURCHASED AT
GUN SHOWS SHOW UP A CALIFORNIA
CRIME SCENES AND ADD TO THE
VICTIMIZATION ARE COMMUTING TO
CIVICALLY IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY AND REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATORS ON THERE ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM
UNFORCED EFFORTS TO DETERMINE
GENERAL STATED THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS STOPPED THE LITTLE ITALY
MANDATED AND FUNDED ENFORCEMENT
OF CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS WITH
THAT SAID THE ORANGE COUNTY
CHOPPER BRADY BELIEVES IS
INCONSISTENT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
PROFIT FROM THE SALE OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION AT GUN SHOWS
TAKING PLACE I SPENT. ON STATE
PROPERTY ALSO INVESTIGATING- AND
INVESTING. TAKING TO REDUCE FIRE
RELATED VIOLENCE. TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT FROM THE INTO FOR JUSTICE
REFORM- QUANTIFY THE OF GUN BY
IN THE CITY OF A- CALIFORNIA
THREE. BUT EACH PART LATER HOW
CONTACT TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE FIRST ESTIMATED THAT NON IN
ESTIMATES TAXPAYERS
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO DOLLAR. ACCORDING TO THE
THIRD FOR ME PROGRESS IN THE
CASE YEAR. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN. THERE WERE
THIRTY THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
THREE PARMELEE HOMICIDE THE
CALIFORNIA. THE REPORT COSTS FOR
FARMERS IN HOMICIDE IN THE CITY
OF STOCKTON THE FARM HOMICIDES
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
APPROXIMATELY. SEVENTY SIX.
HOURS SEVEN SIX BILLION PER
YEAR. CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
PRAGUE PROGRAMS LIKE CAL BETH.
TO FUND COMMUNITY BASED EFFORTS
TO REDUCE FARM WITH THE VIOLENCE
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
GREAT STATE. CALIFORNIA MUST
CONTINUE TO SEEK OPPORTUNITIES
TO REDUCE FARMERS ARE VIOLENCE
CALIFORNIA'S NOT ALLOW ITSELF TO
PROFIT FROM THE SALE OF FIREARMS
AT GUN SHOWS ON STATE PROPERTY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW WILL MOVE TO FORTY
TWO ALL THREE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WOULD SOON A
TESTIFIED. IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE ONE FIVE. SEE NO ONE HERE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES ARE THERE ANY CALLERS.
ONLINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE ONE FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF EXPEDIA NINE ONE
FIVE NEED TO CORRECT ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE ONE
FIVE. AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE
OF FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB NINE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU.
YOU WOULDN'T. THANK YOU WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF THIRTY YEAR
NINE. IT'S GOING ON. SUNDARBANS
FROM GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT SB NINE ONE
FIVE. YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE TWENTY EIGHT. HELLO
THIS IS JENNIFER L'ENFANT
CALLING IN I WOULD NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. Q. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF THE-
HERE FORTY TWO. ROSALES SHARP
FOUNDER OF NEVER AGAIN CA AS
GENERAL ATTORNEY GENERAL STATED
AT THE DEL MAR FAIRGROUNDS
RECENTLY WITH THE GOVERNOR THERE
IS NO OBLIGATION FOR STATE
FAIRGROUNDS TO SELL GUNS THANK
YOU. YOU. THE CARD WITH A BOTTLE
OF WINE THIRTY TWO. HELLO NEAR
ME. HELLO GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MY NAME IS JULIE ADAM LAU
AND I'M WITH WOMEN FOR AMERICAN
VALUES AND ETHICS AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
MANY BELL SB NINE ONE FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU Y.
NUMBER FORTY ONE. HI HI THIS IS
PAPER BANTAM- WITH UNMET BY
WOMEN FOR AMERICAN VALUES AND
ETHICS CALLING IN FIVE SUPPORT
SB. NINE FIFTEEN THANK YOU. Q.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
AND NINE ONE FIVE YOU WOULD NEED
TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
IN Q. MESSENGER. Q. NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION- WILL YOU-
FOUR MINUTES OF FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES ARE IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE DANIEL READ AND WE HAVE
CODY BOILS SO JUST READ IF
YOU'RE PREPARED TO YOU. MAY
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. YOUR CARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD AND REQUEST A REGIONAL
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION. ALSO HERE ARE FOR
GOING TO THE CALIFORNIA WERE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
NINE FIFTEEN. WE FEEL THIS IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO HUNDREDS OF EXISTING
GUN LAWS. GUN LAWS APPLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHETHER. AS
THE PREVIOUS IN SUPPORT- WHETHER
OUT IN YOUR BY BRICK AND MORTAR
OR WHETHER IT AGAIN SHOW. THOSE
LAWS DO APPLY. WITH OUR LAWS YOU
IN THE WAITING PERIOD NO ONE CAN
GO INTO A GUN SHOW. AND CASH AND
CARRY A FIREARM OUT THERE AND A
WAITING PERIOD. WE ALSO HAVE.
ELIGIBILITY CHECKS ARMENIAN. AND
CREEPERS APART WILL BE COMING
JUNE- THIS. LEGISLATION
IMPACTING ALL STATE OWNED
LEASED- GROUNDS. IN. WELL TO AND
SECOND AND THEN PROTECTION PLAN
SHOULD ARE TAX PAYER BY FUND
VENUES WHERE PEOPLE- AND GUN
SHOWS YOU AND BY OWNERSHIP
BECAUSE WE PROTECT THE BACK
CALLED PROTECTED ARE. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT THERE IS NOT A
PROLIFERATE THE LEGAL FOR GUNS-
OUR POINTS BUT I MY TIME IS
LIMITED I WEREN'T STRONG ENOUGH
. TO THAT THANK YOU. THANK NEXT
WITH THIS IS CODY BOILS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CODY
BOILED INBEHALF OF THE WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED SB NINE
FIFTEEN THIRTY THAT THEY
REPRESENT THE STATE SEVENTY FOUR
FAIRGROUNDS THAT HELPS SEVENTY
SEVEN PAIRS AND IT CONCLUDES ALL
CALIFORNIA'S DISTRICT AGATA
STATION AS WELL AS THE STATE
FAIR- JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT ALL
GUN SHOWS ON FAIRGROUNDS ARE
REQUIRED TO ABIDE BY THE
REGULATIONS SET FORTH. IN THE
GUN SHOW AND FORCE AN ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND STATE LAW ALSO MANDATES
THAT ALL FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS
TAKE QUITE THAT TAKE PLACE ON
FAIRGROUNDS BE SUBJECT TO THE
STANDARD TEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
WHILE ALSO REQUIRING A FIREARM
TO REMAIN POSSESSION OF THE
TRANSACTING DEALER UNTIL A
PERIOD AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HOW TO COMPLETE THE
REQUIRED. BACKGROUND CHECK ON
THE PURCHASER IS YOUR GALLAGHER
CULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS RECEIVE
MINIMAL SUPPORT IN THE STATE
BUDGET AND AS A RESULT FARES ARE
EXPECTED TO GENERATE THEIR OWN
REVENUES FROM TRADE SHOWS
LIVESTOCK AUCTIONS CONCERTS AND
OTHER EVENTS EACH OF THE EACH OF
OUR AFFAIRS- HOST EVENTS-
INTEREST TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THE SERVER AND THEY ARE
SERVED- BY BOARDS THAT ARE
GOVERNED BY RESIDENTS OF THE.
READY TO BAN GUN SHOWS IF THEY
SO CHOOSE AND WE SUPPORT EVERY.
DECISION TO MAKE- THOSE TO MAKE
IT THOSE DECISIONS- THAT
REFLECT. THE VALUES AND THE- THE
WANTS OF THEIR OF THEIR
COMMUNITY WE LASTLY WE AGREED
FORMER- FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN POSITION AT LOCAL
FAIRGROUNDS ARE BEST EQUIPPED TO
DECIDE WHAT KINDS OF EVENTS.
THAT TAKE PLACE- ON THEIR
PROGRAMS AND I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE LASTLY- THE AUTHOR
STAFFERS WLL BE COMMITTEE
STAFFER DISCUSSIONS REGARDING SB
NINE FIFTEEN AND OTHER
ITERATIONS- THIS BILL IN THE
PAST AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
FURTHER DIALOGUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW WE MOVE TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE ONE
FIVE. HEARING TÍNH ON IN PERSON
. MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF SP
NINE ONE FAR. YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION S. ZERO NINE ONE FIVE
IT IS ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
AND THROWING GROUP AS
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION MYSELF AND OR
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. YOU
NEXT WITNESS. I NUMBER FIFTY.
THANKS FOR YOUR VENTURA COUNTY
RESIDENT STRONG OPPOSITION. NEXT
WITNESS. I AM A BORDER THIRTY
SIX PEOPLE HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CARLENE ELLIS WHEN THE
COMPETITIVE SHOOTER I AM ALSO A
TAXPAYER IN CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND OF
THE ARMS WOMEN OF AMERICA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. BRIAN AT
NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE CALL HAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BILLY
CAMERON WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. YOU NEXT WITNESS. NO BY
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BILL GAINES SPEAKING TODAY
ABOUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEER
ASSOCIATION THE ROCKY MOUNTAIN
ELK FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
BUT ONE HUNDRED STATE ARCHERY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSE. FOR CONSERVATION. BASIN
WELLINGTON SOLICITATION THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE WILD
SHEEP FOUNDATION THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER OF
PARTICLE BETTER NATIONAL BANK
EAGLE COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION. CAL OR WELL INTO
WATER TOWN COUNCIL AND THE BLACK
BRANT GROUP IT'S WRONG
OPPOSITION THE SENATE BILL NINE
FIFTEEN. OUR. WE HAVELIFELINE
NUMBER FORTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS STEVE RIDER WITH THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION U.
S. NAVY VET RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THE COMMITTEE TO
OPPOSE SB NINE ONE FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO ADDRESS. WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX. MY
NUMBER FORTY SIX TO LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JOHN O'BRIEN OKAY.
MY NAME IS JAMES O'BRIEN I'M A
CO GAME S. B. NINE ONE FIVE- IN
MY FORTY YEAR. CALIFORNIA
HUNTING LICENSE HOLDER FISHING
LICENSE HOLDER. I AM ALSO A
LIFELONG RESIDENT CALIFORNIA-
LOWS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IS
DID YOU NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. SORRY WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE
GRANT I'M THE CHAIR OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND AN ARMY MEMBER.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOST
SIX HUNDRED- LOOSING A TAURUS-
WHO SIGNED A PETITION IN FAVOR
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY. ON SHOW-
ARE YOU AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE SP NINE FIFTEEN THANK YOU
THE QUICKNESS. NEXT WHAT IF LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAT HURTIN
I'M A LIFE MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION LIFE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION. BERMAN
OF THE TEAM ACCOUNTING GUN
OWNERS CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION.
AND A RETIRED SERGEANT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. I AM
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B.
NINE FIFTEEN AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. EXCELLENT NEXT.
NINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
MIKE ELLIOTT I'M A REGULAR AND A
VENTURA COUNTY MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO THE VENTURA
COUNTY GUN OWNERS GROUP. I URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE SB NINE ONE FIVE
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF INFORMATION
A LOT OF MISINFORMATION. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WOULD YOU
PLEASE NAME YOUR RESERVATION
NUMBER OF. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HAVE A LINE OVER FORTY
NINE. THIS IS JIM WESTFALL
MEMBER OF C. A. R. P. A. AND
THEN R. A. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE QUICKNESS. WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS ELISE HUNT LIKE CANDY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT I'M A
COMPETITIVE SHOOTER AND ARCHER
I'M WITH THE RPA AND THE RAIN
STATE THE OFFICER I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY GOODNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN. BY NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN YOUR OPEN. TURNING TO
LEGAL TO THE LINE OF FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
PETER STEIN WITH WOMEN FOR
AMERICAN VALUES AND ETHICS. ONLY
ONE BECAUSE THE ASIAN BUT THE
NAME SAYS IT ALL AND I'M
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE FIFTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS WERE TAKEN
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF ESPIONAGE NINE ONE
FIVE IT IS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN. KELLY
HOPKINS BUT THE CONVENTIONAL
ORDNANCE FOUNDATION HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION. YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAUL
CAPS SOME ASSISTANT OF VENTURA
COUNTY AND AN ATTENDEE AT THE
VENTURA COUNTY GUN SHOW ON A
REGULAR BASIS I ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND **** I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE ONE FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY FINE
NUMBER FIFTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT ALEXANDER
BRADFORD NUMBER TWO COMMITTEE
CAPPING RANCH REPRESENTING
OUTDOORS WORKING COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY AND THE FIGHT
CLUB INTERNATIONAL IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WINANT NUMBER. SIXTY GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS RON LANDER AND CHAIRMAN OF
THE RIVERSIDE CHAPTER OF THE N.
C. R. PA MYSELF MY CHAPTER IN
ALL THE FAMILIES MY CHAPTER
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE ONE FIVE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT AND A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. YEAH NINE ONE
FIVE. YOU NEED TO DIAL ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY COMING OUT IN OPPOSITION
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU HAVE
AFTER HEARING FROM BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL NOT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WINNER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
SO I. STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS I DID LAST YEAR- HAS BEEN A
LONG HISTORY HERE TO- FOR A LONG
TIME IT WAS FOCUS AND- MY
COMMUNITY- WITH THE COW PALACE-
WHICH WAS PUTTING ON GUN SHOWS
FOR DECADES DESPITE THE FACT
THAT HE WAS. HERE ALMOST HER
PERSONALLY OPPOSE IN SAN
FRANCISCO CEMETERY COUNTY BY
SCHOOL BOARDS AND CITY COUNCILS
AND BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND IT'S A
STUBBORNLY KEPT DOING IT FOR
DECADES- AND SO. SENATE-ROOM
DATA CENTER JACKIE SPEAR SENATOR
MARK LENO AND MYSELF AND THE
FILTERING WORK- YOU KNOW.
MONNING BILL AFTER BILL AND
SHORT VETOED A GOVERNOR- BROWN-
VETOED IT AND- EVENTUALLY BE
INTERESTED TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
LAND ENTIRELY AND TRANSFERRED TO
DALY CITY AND SAN FRANCISCO AND
THAT FINALLY GOT THEIR
ATTENTION- AND- THEY VOLUNTARILY
STOPPED- THE GUN SHOWS BUT IT
SHOULD SHOWS. THE PROBLEMS HERE
WE HAVE THESE STATE AGRICULTURE
FOR OUR AGRICULTURAL FAIRGROUNDS
I KEEP- PUTTING ON THESE
COUNTRIES REGARDLESS OF WHAT A
LOCAL COMMUNITY WANTS- BUT JUST
BEYOND ALL OF THAT. HI YOU NEED
TO BE VERY CLEAR THESE GUNS.
OVERWHELMINGLY SERVE ONE PURPOSE
AND ONE PURPOSE AND ONE PURPOSE
ONLY TO KILL. AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
AND THAT IS WHY THESE KINDS
EXISTS- FOR TALKING ABOUT
HUNTING RIFLES THAT SAID YOU
KNOW IT A DIFFERENT STORY BEFORE
TALKING ABOUT A BROAD ARRAY OF
GUNS. THAT OVERWHELMINGLY EXIST
TO KILL PEOPLE. WE SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWING THOSE TO BE SOLD ON
STATE PROPERTY IT'S AGAINST OUR
VALUES. AND WE KNOW THAT. HAVING
MORE GUNS MEANS THAT MORE PEOPLE
GET SHOT. THAT'S LIKE THAT
EMPIRICALLY PROVEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THE WHOLE NOTION THAT THE
ONLY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD PEOPLE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING
AROUND GOING ON CRIME SPREES
TRAGEDY THAT'S THAT'S NOT TRUE
YES THOSE PEOPLE ARE ARE KILLING
PEOPLE IN THE MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
HORRIFIC BUT SO MANY SHOOTINGS.
ARE YOU KNOW ACCIDENTAL HI IN
NATURE SO MANY SHOOTINGS HAPPEN
IN THE HEAT OF THE MOMENT NOT
BECAUSE SOMEONE WENT OUT
INTENDING ORIGINALLY TO KILL
SOMEONE THE MORE GUNS WE HAVE
THE MORE PEOPLE. GET SHOT AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY WELL YOU
SAW SHOOTINGS IN CALIFORNIA
DESPITE YOUR STRONG LAWS AREBUT
OUR RATES ARE LOWER THAN STATES
THAT HAVE WEAKER LAWS AND IN
FACT THEY'RE MORE SHOOTINGS THAT
HAPPENED NEAR THE MATA GET THE
NEVADA BORDER BECAUSE IN THE
BOTTOM THERE ARE LOOSER. LAWS O
HAVING LESS ACCESS TO GUNS-
MEANS FEWER PEOPLE- GOT SHOT AND
FEWER PEOPLE- DIED- AND SO I
THINK IT MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN
THE WORLD BONTA AND GUN SALES
AND STATE PROPERTY AND I MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION OF A ON THE SIDE.
CENTER FIVE ZERO STROLL BOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK. AS A PROPONENT OF LOCAL
CONTROL I- I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTIONS TO ISSUES I DO NOT
THINK THAT IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
MANDATE EVERY AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICT AND FAIRGROUND IN THE
STATE WHAT ACTIVITIES THEY CAN.
HOLD ON THEIR PROPERTY WHEN
THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE ABIDING BY
LOCAL REGULATIONS. THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE MORE
APPROPRIATE AT A LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE EVERY OPPORTUNITY EVERY
OPPORTUNITY GIVEN TO THE LOCAL
PROPONENTS AND THE OPPONENTS OF
GUN SHOWS TO MAKE THEIR CASE IN
FRONT OF THE BOARD OF MEMBERS. A
FRIEND OF BOARD MEMBERS WHO ARE
APPOINTED. APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. GUN SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RIGOROUS
REQUIREMENTS FOR VENDORS AND
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE WITH THE APPOINTED
WORDS HAVE MADE THE
DETERMINATION THAT THESE LEGAL
SHOWS REFLECT THE NEEDS AND
DESIRES OF THEIR IDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES ACCORDING TO THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA PORAC THE GUN SHOWS
IN CALIFORNIA MUST COMPLY WITH
OVER TWENTY SIX SECTIONS. OF
PENAL CODE. BY CHECKING IT OUT.
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
HAVE A RIGHT TO EQUAL ACCESS TO
ENGAGE IN LEGAL ACTIVITIES ON
OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED FAIRGROUNDS
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT LEGAL
ACTIVITY WE MIGHT SEEK TO BAN
NEXT IF WE SET DOWN THIS PATH.
AND MAY I ADD ON A PERSONAL NOTE
THAT. I EMPATHIZE AND TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE FEAR THAT YOU MAY
HAVE- STANDARD MEANT WHEN YOU GO
TO AND YOU FINISH AT A MARATHON
WITH YOUR FAMILIES AND YOUR
HANDED EIGHTY A FLYER FOR A GUN
SHOW BUT FOR SOME FAMILIES
INCLUDING MANY OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS INCLUDING FAMILY FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS- A- FAMILY CULTURAL
RITES OF PASSAGE- WHATEVER YOU
MAY CALL IT IT'S A FAMILY
ENDEAVOR FROM ANY OF THEM IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS DONE IN A
POSITIVE SAFE EDUCATED
ENVIRONMENT FOR MANY OF THEM AND
IT'S A LITTLE DISTURBING TO
THINK THAT WE ARE PUTTING A-
OVERALL MMHM. RIGHT ON PEOPLE
WHO ENGAGE IN THIS SPACE BECAUSE
NOT EVERYONE IS OUT THERE TO
SHOOT AND KILL PEOPLE SOMETIMES
IT'S JUST FAMILY TRADITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED ON FOR
GENERATIONS AND WE SHOULD
RESPECT WE TALK ABOUT RESPECTING
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO- YOU KNOW
LIVE THEIR CULTURE LIVE THEIR
LIVES AND SO FORTH AND- THEY'RE
NOT THE CULPRITS HERE. HOWEVER I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR AND ACKNOWLEDGE IS
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COMPONENT
ARE CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE AS A
STATE AND AS A NATION. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE MUST. CHEST
WHOLEHEARTEDLY EMBRACED IN A
DRESS- IN OUR IN OUR IN OUR
CULTURE AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I RAN FOR OFFICE IS TO
ADDRESS TOXICITY THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR CULTURE. AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT WE HAVE TO BE YOU KNOW ACT
IN A WAY THAT- CONTINUES TO
PROMOTE CIVILIZED RESPECTFUL
MEANS OF- INTERACTION. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS AND WE SEE IF I
HAVE ALL MY NOTES ADDRESSED HERE. I THINK FOR THOSE REASONS AT
THIS TIME I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT BOB THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY BY MEMBERS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE- NINETEEN
NINE I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
THIS MEASURE TO MEASURE THAT WE
HEARD LAST YEAR AND- CHAU WHICH
NOTHING NEW TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED ON BOTH
SIDES- BUT AS STATED- IT SO
ELOQUENTLY FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO IT'S NOT
ABOUT. DENYING ONE'S SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHT IT'S ABOUT
WINNING WHERE. THESE GUNS ARE
BEING SOLD IN A TYPE OF GUNS ARE
BEING SOLD AND- NOT INFRINGING
ON INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS TO HOT BUT
A. K. FORTY SEVENS AND- THOSE
TYPE OF ASSAULT WEAPONS THAT ARE
DESIGNED HAS STATED TO. KILL
MASS PEOPLE QUICKLY YOU
SHOULDN'T BE SOLD ON ANY STATE
PROPERTY I'M A FIRM BELIEVER OF
AND I THINK THEY HAVE. NO VALUE-
WHATSOEVER OTHER THAN
DESTRUCTION ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
GET IN THE HANDS OF THE WRONG
INDIVIDUALS AND AS WE SAW. JUST
ON A LITTLE OVER A MONTH AGO- IN
ANOTHER INCH STATE. A LEGALLY
PURCHASED GUN THAT GOT IN AHEAD
OF THEIR TEENAGER AND HE- SHOT
THREE SCHOOL. MEMBERS MET FOR
FOUR SHOTS SO- WE KNOW ACCIDENTS
HAPPEN BUT SO. I THINK THIS IS
JUST TRYING TO EXTEND- THE
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS TO MAKING
SURE THAT. GUNS ARE SHOWN IN A
MORE PROPER PLACE AT A GUN STORE
PURCHASE. ART COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
SHOW- WITH THAT WE- WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'D APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMMENTS ON RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. WE HAVE A MY FOR SENATOR
WIENER. WE HAVE A TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON S. B.
NINE ONE FIVE. SB NINE ONE FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE TRABAJO
NO TROUBLE NO COME LONGER. AND
LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE FORTY ONE.
CENTERMAN THE BILLS OUT FOR THE
ONE CONGRATULATIONS NEXT UP WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE
GABRIEL AND- HE HAS. A A. J. R.
TWENTY TWO.
WHEN YOU READY YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I
WILL BE BRIEF I INTRODUCED HR
TWENTY TWO WHEN I REALIZE THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE IN SESSION ON
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
JANUARY SIX INSURRECTION- FELT
MOST APPROPRIATE TO ME. AND
REALLY- ESSENTIAL THAT ARE
LEGISLATURE GO ON RECORD ABOUT
THIS EVENT. IMPART BECAUSE
ALMOST AS DISTURBING AS THE-
EVENTS OF THAT DAY WHICH WERE
HARD TO. HARD TO PROCESS IS THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE FOLKS IN OUR
COUNTRY WHO ARE TRYING TO
REWRITE HISTORY. REWRITE HISTORY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT DAY.
TO ROLL BACK VOTING RIGHTS TO
REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEGITIMACY OF FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS. WHO ARE PROMOTING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
MISINFORMATION THAT WOULD A
ROADS- FAITH IN GOVERNMENT AND
FAITH IN DEMOCRACY AND SO THIS
TO ME FELT LIKE AN IMPORTANT
MOMENT FOR US AS A STATE. AND A
STATE TO TAKE SUCH A LEADING
ROLE TO HAVE MEMBERS GO ON
RECORD ABOUT JANUARY SIX TO
CONDEMN IT- TO REJECT POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IN ALL ITS FORMS TO.
EXPRESS OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE-
HUNDRED FORTY MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT WERE INJURED
THAT DAY TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
COURAGE AND BRAVERY AND
SACRIFICE OF THE FOLKS WHO WERE
INJURED AND KILLED. DEFENDING
UNITED TATES CAPITOL. AND ALSO
TO REMEMBER HOW FRAGILE
DEMOCRACY IS AND HOW MUCH WORK
WE HAVE TO DO TO PROTECT IT SO.
WE HAD A VIGOROUS DEBATE ON THIS
IN- IN OUR HOUSE WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF FOLKS
IN THE SENATE ON A J. R. TWENTY
TWO. YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THOSE
MEASURE NONE LISTED- MAR IS
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE
PRESIDENT WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A G. R. A H. A R.
TWENTY TWO. SHE NINE MODERATE
CAN WE GO TO FOLLOWING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE. WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF A AJ R. TWENTY TWO IS
ONE OF THEM ZERO. ONCE AGAIN I
WAS IN SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE.
TWENTY TWO ONE NINEZERO. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY CARRYING ON THE
TRADITION. YOU ON WALL AND WE
HAVE NO ONE HERE PRESENT ALL
RIGHT NOW WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE. WELL LET
ME JUST BACK UP IS ANYONE
PRESENT HERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. AJ ARE TWENTY TWO
. IN CHAIN NINE MODERATE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES INTO THIRDS
ANYONE ONLINE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AJ ARE TWENTY
CUBITS ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY GEARING UP MISTER
CHAIR BREAK WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS RELATES
TO AG ARE. TWENTY TWO. THIS
CENTER CONNOR I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE. TIME WE
HAVE A MOTION IN SUPPORT OF A J.
R. TWENTY TWOS. NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE BY COLLEAGUES JUST- SHE'S
JUST GONNA CURIOUS. ARE THE
DESTINATIONS ALREADY GOING ON.
YEAH YES THEY ARE SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I THINK YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN THAT- YOU HAD THE DAY
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE- RECENTLY
FILE EVIDENCE IN FEDERAL COURT
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
VIOLATED MULTIPLE LAWS IN AN
EFFORT TO OVERTURN OUR ELECTION
AND SO WE FELT THAT WAS MOST
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THAT THERE.
ARE SO MANY WHO ARE OPPOSING THE
WORK OF THE BIPARTISAN SELECT
COMMITTEE THAT OUR STATE STANDS
FIRMLY IN SUPPORT OF THAT AND
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THEM TO
DO A THOROUGH TRANSPARENT- AND
RIGOROUS INVESTIGATION TO
UNCOVER EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED ON
THAT DAY. THIS I BELIEVE IS IT
WAS REALLY A SEMINAL MOMENT IN
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY AND I
THINK ONE THAT ALL OF US WILL
REMEMBER FOR OUR ENTIRE LIVES-
AND PROBABLY OUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS WILL TALK ABOUT- SO TO
ME IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT
OUR STATE BE ON THE RECORD ABOUT
THAT PARTICULARLY BECAUSE WE
WERE IN SESSION. ON THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF AND SO THIS WOULD
JUST TRANSMIT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE PRESIDENT THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOX AND CONGRESS
ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR A-
THOROUGH INDEPENDENT INDEPENDENT
AND BIPARTISAN INVESTIGATION
JANUARY SIXTH. AT THE CALIFORNIA
SAID- ELECTED EYES. I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS ON ON. CALIFORNIA ISSUES
BUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD AND- AND ACTION THAT
THIS IS A FEDERAL ISSUE. AT A
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT I UNDERSTAND
THE MERITS BEHIND- YOUR INTENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER.
INTERSTELLAR THANKYOU I CHAIR-
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE WHILE IT IS TRUE
THAT IT IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO ACT AND IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT OCCURRED WITHOUT
OUR CAPITAL. I THINK THE VERY-
THOSE OF US WHO WATCHED IN
HORROR AS IT OCCURRED. THE
CONSEQUENCES. ONE COULD IMAGINE
SOME VERY SEVERE CONSEQUENCES.
FROM THAT DAY. THAT COULD HAVE
INCLUDED- WELL FIRST OFF THE-
CASUALLY THE DEATHS OF SOME
LEGISLATORS. ON EVEN POTENTIALLY
THE VICE PRESIDENT BECAUSE AT
THE TIME MUCH OF THE BE- ANGER
WITH FOCUSED ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT IN HIS ROLE TO CERTIFY
THE ELECTION- AND IT COULD'VE
COST POTENTIALLY A LACK OF
CERTIFICATION OF A LEGITIMATE
ELECTION. SO UP ND EVERY ASPECT
OF WHAT WE THREE KAMAR CHRISSY
IS A MESSY BUSINESS JUST BECAUSE
IT'S THE NATURE OF IT IS SUCH
THAT- WE ALLOW. VOTERS TO CHOOSE
THE REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES AS LONG AS ALL
OF US TAKE THE OATH HE SWORE TO
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION AS LONG
AS THEY ARE. ACTING WITHIN THEIR
- DEFENDING THE CONSTITUTION
THEN THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MOVE IN DIRECTIONS THAT YOU KNOW
SOME OF US DON'T AGREE WITH. BUT
IN THIS CASE. IN ANY
INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION THAT WAS A
VIOLATION. OF WHAT OUR
CONSTITUTION INDICATES AND SO. I
FEEL LIKE IT IS OF SUCH THE
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE COULD HAVE
BEEN SO SEVERE AND COULD STILL
IMPACT NOT ONLY THE STATE. THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE. BUT IF HE
ALL OF US AS INDIVIDUALS. THAT I
THINK IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE FOR
US TO ASK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. EXPRESS WHAT WE FEEL
SHOULD HAPPEN IN THIS SERVICE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT A PROPER
INVESTIGATION HAPPENED SO
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FORWARD.
YEAH I FIGURE THAT'S AND I JUST
OUT OF MY MISTER CHAIRMAN. YOU
KNOW REMIND EVERYBODY THE OATH
THAT WE ALL TAKE WHEN WE ARE
SWORN IN AS MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND BEFORE OUR DUTY
TO DEFEND AND PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALL A FIRM THAT
WE WILL PROTECT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. SO I THINK IT'S VERY
MUCH INGRAINED IN THE DUTIES
THAT WE HAVE AS MEMBERS OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND SQUARELY
WITHIN OUR PURVIEW AND TO ME
THIS IS. DIRECTLY ON POINT WE
HAVE FOLKS WHO ATTACKED AND
ATTEMPTED TO UNDERMINE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY. AND SUBVERT THE WILL
OF OUR VOTERS AND WE HAVE FOLKS
ARE TRYING TO REWRITE HISTORY
ABOUT THAT AND SO IT SEEMS TO ME
AS FOLKS WHO HAVE. SWORN AN
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO SPEAK UP ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER THANK
YOU- YEAH I. YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY- I THINK IT'S REALLY
AND CALIFORNIA'S INTERESTS TO
HAVE A FULL INVESTIGATION. OF
WHAT WAS. REALLY A- TREASON S.
EFFORT. TO HAVE AN- ARMED
OVERTHROW OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS WHAT THIS-WAS- THE STAFF IN CALIFORNIA'S
INTEREST FOR THAT TO BE FULLY
INVESTIGATED. SO WE CAN TAKE
STEPS PER NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN- IS
YOU KNOW. RELATING TO MY
DISTRICT ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY WANTED TO KILL THAT DAY WAS
WAS MY REPRESENTATIVE IN
CONGRESS ON NANCY PELOSI'S
REPRESENTS SAN FRANCISCO FOR.
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND DONE SO
ADMIRABLY ADMIRABLY AND SHE WAS
ON THEIR LIST OF PEOPLE. TO KILL
DHANBAD DAY ON THANK GOD SHE WAS
IN HER OFFICE WHEN THEY INVADED
IT- BECAUSE SHE MIGHT NO LONGER
BE WITH US AND SO MY
CONSTITUENTS- ARE VERY
PROTECTIVE OF OUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS. AND SO WE WANT TO
INVESTIGATION- WE KNOW THERE
WERE THREATS AGAINST CALIFORNIA
CAPITOL IN THE WAKE OF THAT ARMS
AT ARMS EFFORT TO OVERTHROW. THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT AND WE
ALL REMEMBER WHAT THE SECURITY
CALLED PRECAUTIONS THAT WE HAD
FOR A LONG TIME AFTER THAT WERE
THE ENTIRE. CAPITAL WAS
BARRICADED- AND SO- IT DIRECTLY
IMPACTED US. I'M OUT I ALSO
THINK THAT. YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THEY WERE TO DO THEY'RE TRYING
TO STEAL CALIFORNIA'S VOICE- BY
YOU KNOW WE HAD FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE AND ALL OVER
MANY MILLIONS OF. OF VOTES IN
CALIFORNIA WAS VERY CLEAR ABOUT
HOW VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN AND-
DISCOVER. MORE HAVE JUST
INVALIDATED THE VOICE OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WE
ALREADY- GET SCREWED OVER BY
HAVING TWO UNITED STATES
SENATORS THE SAME AS- NORTH
DAKOTA AND RHODE ISLAND NO
DISRESPECT TO THOSE STATES BUT
WE ARE DRAMATICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED. IN THE U. S.
SENATE AND ALSO IN THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE- BUT THE LEAST. THEY CAN
DO IS COUNT OUR VOTES FOR
PRESIDENT AND- DIS
INSURRECTIONIST WE'RE TRYING TO
INVALIDATE CALIFORNIA'S VOTE SO
DIRECTLY TIES. TO INTERESTS OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS. YOU SENATOR
COLLAR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I MOVED
THE BILL- IS BECAUSE I DO THINK
THAT CALIFORNIA IS A BELLWETHER
STATE AND HOPEFULLY IF THIS IS
PASSED- IT WILL ENCOURAGE OTHER
STATES. TO LOOK AT LEGISLATION
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS- THE
INSURRECTION ONJANUARY SIXTH-
NEEDS TO BE THOROUGHLY
INVESTIGATED NOT ONLY WERE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS PUT AT RISK
AND THE VICE PRESIDENT. BUT
ALSO. TEAMS OF STAFF AND IN. WHO
GO TO THOSE BUILDINGS EVERY DAY
TO DO THE WORK OF THE PEOPLE AND
HOPEFULLY THIS INVESTIGATION
WILL ALLOW US TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PROPERLY TRAIN AND SUPPORT
THOSE. STAFF WHO COME IN EVERY
DAY TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
CONSTITUENT SERVICES TO THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AND CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE DESERVING OF A GOVERNMENT
THAT WORKS FOR THEM. WHEN THE
OTHER REALITY IS THAT JANUARY
SIXTH TRIGGERED AN AVALANCHE OF
VOLATILITY ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THAT NOW HINGES ON THE
IRRATIONAL AND I THINK WE NEED
AN INVESTIGATION TO ALLOW US TO
COME BACK TO SOME SHARED TRUTHS
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY ALLOW US TO
MEND A VERY FRAGILE AND YET
INTERNATIONALLY CRITICAL
DEMOCRACY SO THAT IS WHY I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU AND I TO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS COMMONSENSE MEASURE
AND FOR ANYONE TO BELIEVE WHAT
HAPPENED. JANUARY SIXTH OF LAST
YEAR WAS ACT THE PATRIOTISM I'M-
I'M I'M I'M A STAUNCH ASTOUNDED
BY THAT AND IF THAT'S WITH
DIRECT DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE I
WANT NO PART OF IT I MEAN FOR
FIVE PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR LIVES
FOUR HUNDRED OFFICERS. TO BE
INJURED AND FOR MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN DAMAGES TO OUR
NATIONAL NATION'S CAPITAL AND
FOR SOMEBODY SAID THAT TO ACT
THE PATRIOTISM- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT KIND OF PITCHER TO THOSE
ARE IT WAS. DEFINITELY TREASON
AND HIGHWAY- USE HATE TO PLAY
THIS CAR BUT ARE YOU SURE YOU
HAVE THOSE WERE BLACK
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD STORMED A
CAPITAL LIKE THAT IT WOULD BE NO
QUESTION A WHAT. THEY WOULD BE
CALLING US IN THIS COUNTRY AND
PEOPLE WOULD SET THEIR HAIR ON
FIRE IF NOT EVERYONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WERE PROSECUTED BUT
IN THE FACT MAJORITY MORE WHITE
MALES ME. FOR MILITARY AND SOME
YOU KNOW POLICE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE HAD A PLEA SHE FROM
CALIFORNIA WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THAT SO WE SHOULD ASK CALIFORNIA
WANT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS AND HAVE A FULL
INVESTIGATION. AND SET AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT DEMOCRACY LOOKS
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND QUESTIONING
ANYTHING THAT TOOK PART TOWARD
DEMOCRACY WHICH JANUARY FOR SIX
WAS CLEARLY SO. I WILL SEND THE
WINNER. POSITIVENESS I'M A
SOMEONE I'M I'M A WERE TO. IN
THE BEGINNING- AND THE REASON I
SAID THAT WAS- DRUDGERY WE KNOW
THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT FUEL TO
THIS INSURRECTION. THE MONTHS
AND MONTHS OF LIES AND
MISINFORMATION AND PROPAGANDA ON
SOCIAL MEDIA- IT WAS DOMESTIC
BUT WE ALSO KNOW. THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN WAS HELPING TO FUND THAT.
OF THAT NOT JUST OF. GOVERNMENT
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT THAT IS
COMPLETELY HOSTILE. TO DEMOCRACY
TO OUR GOVERNMENT FOR GOVERNMENT
THAT- IS NOW TRYING TO LOOK
CONCORD. AND CARPET BOMB
CIVILIANS IN A DEMOCRACY- AND
THAT WE CAN COME OUT OF THE
BLUE. RUSHES IN TALKING ABOUT
THINGS AND TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A LONG TIME SO WE HAVE A
BRUTAL FASCIST DICTATOR THAT'S
TRYING TO CONQUER. A DEMOCRACY
AND THAT SAME BRUTAL FASCIST
DICTATOR WAS. USING HIS TROLL
FARMS INTERNET TROLL FARMS TO
TRY TO. FUEL THE PROPAGANDA THAT
LED DIRECTLY TO THIS
INSURRECTION SO IT'S NOT JUST.
DOMESTIC TERRORISM AND
INSURRECTION THAT WE SAW WE
STILL ON JANUARY SIXTH IT WAS AN
EFFORT BY A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
TO TOPPLE THE U. S. GOVERNMENT.
IT'S JUST JUST TO REFLECT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS JOHN
SKIPPER WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHARGES
ONE APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION FROM MY COLLEAGUES
I THINK THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
STEP FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD AS A
NATION. WITH A SHARED PATH THE
SENATE OR CONGRESS THAT IS TO
BE- IT'S TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY SIXTH AND AS
COMPLICATED AS DIFFICULT AS THAT
IS TO JUST TELL THE TRUTH- AND
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE TRUTH
AND ALL OF ITS COLORS. AND
HAVING A VERY CLEAR DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT IN A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE NEED TO
DO AS A SOCIETY TO MOVE PAST
THIS VIOLENT TREASONOUS ATTACK
ON OUR GOVERNMENT- TO ME IS OF
THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE AND
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THE TRUTH
WILL SET YOU FREE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR COM AUGER-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ON S. B. AJ ARE TWENTY TWO
MAJOR TWENTY TWO MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED BRADFORD HI BRADFORD
DIETRO BUG THAT VOTING IN A
TROUBLED NOT VOTING COM
MODERNIZE COME LONGER AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE FOUR ZERO.
MEASUREMENTS FOR VOTES AND HAS
BEEN ADOPTED SO CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
. NOW HER FINAL. BILL OF THE DAY
IT'S S. B. EIGHT THREE SIX BY
CENTER WINNER HE'S GETTING
PREPARED WHEN YOU'RE READY
CENTER WINNER YOU MAY BEGIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES
AFTER HEARING THIS BILL TODAY
BUT IF THIS BILL MAY LOOK
FAMILIAR SB EIGHT THIRTY SIX IS-
IS THERE A RERUN OF A BILL THAT
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED AND WAS.
SIGNED INTO LAW A FEW YEARS BACK
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FIVE
UNFORTUNATELY SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE- EXPIRED AT THE END OF LAST
YEAR SO WE ARE QUICKLY TRYING TO
GET IT REAL AUTHORIZED AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS VERY SIMPLE.
IT PROVIDES THAT WHEN- WHEN
SOMEONE'S TESTIFYING IN COURT AN
ATTORNEY CAN NOT. ASK THAT
WITNESS QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS UNLESS THEIR
FIRST ONE S. R. PRESENTED TO THE
JUDGE. WHY THE QUESTION WOULD BE
RELEVANT THANK GOD I AM THE
JUDGE'S RULING THAT ITS
RELEVANCE- THERE ARE SITUATIONS
WHERE IMMIGRATION STATUS OF A
WITNESS CAN BE RELEVANT TO A
CASE THAT MIGHT BE RELEVANT. TO
THE TO THE CLAIM ITSELF FOR TO
AN AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE ON
HOWEVER WHAT WE- WE'RE SEEING
AYE SITUATIONS WHERE A LAWYER
WHICH HAS RANDOMLY ASK SOMEONE
WHAT'S YUR IMMIGRATION STATUS
ON WHICH CAN BE A FORM OF-
INTIMIDATION. OF A WITNESS. FIVE
AND- WITHOUT HAVING ANY
RELEVANCE TO THE CASE AND WE
KNOW THAT IN RECENT YEARS- THAT
THAT ICE WAS IN COURT HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA- AND SO BY SENDING A
SIGNAL THAT IF YOU. ARE A VICTIM
OF A CRIME OR A WITNESS TO A
CRIME OR A CIVIL WITNESS THAT IF
YOU GO TO COURT THAT MIGHT CAUSE
YOU TO GET DEPORTED BECAUSE
SOMEONE'S GOING TO ASK YOU AND
STANDS. ABOUT IMMIGRATION STATUS
THAT'S- CHRIS HUGHTON'S SIDE OF
FOR IMMIGRANTS NOT TO GO TO
COURT- AND THAT UNDERMINES ALL
OF OUR SAFETY- WE NEED. ALL
RESIDENTS INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
pSAFE REPORTING CRIMES IN GOING
TO COURT. TO TESTIFY- SO AGAIN
THIS DOES NOT PRECLUDE.
ATTORNEYS FROM SEEKING TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS IF IT'S RELEVANT ALL THEY
HAVE TO DO JUST LIKE IN A SEXUAL
ASSAULT TRIAL IF YOU WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE VICTIM'S SEXUAL
HISTORY YOU CAN'T JUST ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE TO. PRESENTED-TO THE JUDGE FIRST EXPLAIN WHY
IT'S RELEVANT AND THE JUDGE WILL
RULE THE SUPPLIES A SIMILAR
APPROACH- THIS IS A GOOD BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THREE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I SEE YOU HAVE
TO LEAD WITNESSES ARE ON THE
LINE WE HAVE DANIEL FELIZ AUTO.
AM RESEARCH D. S. DENTAL SADO
FROM THE L. A. T. IS OFFICE AND
MERCED DHEAS FROM LEGAL AID AT
WORK YES WILL AFFORD YOU FOUR
MINUTES. TOTAL TWO MINUTES- WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TEMPLES OUT
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AS A SENATOR STATED-
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF SB
SEVENTY FIVE THERE WERE NUMEROUS
EXAMPLES OF ATTORNEYS DISCLOSING
THE IMMIGRATION STATUS OF CRIME
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES AND-
CRIMINAL CASES. ADDITIONALLY
UNDER THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
WE UNFORTUNATE HAD THE PRESENCE
OF- IMMIGRATION AGENTS MAKING
ARRESTS AT OUR CALIFORNIA
COURTHOUSES COMBINED THIS CAUSED
A TREMENDOUS A CHILLING EFFECT
ON THAT THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES WILLINGNESS TO COME
TO COURT AND TESTIFY. THE
CHILLING EFFECT WAS SO GREAT
THAT ARE CHIEF JUSTICE WROTE A
LETTER TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXPRESSING CONCERN ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AGENTS STAKING OUT
CALIFORNIA COURT HOUSES. IN A
LETTER TO THE CHIEF JUSTICE
POINTED OUT THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO HAVE SAFE
ACCESS TO OUR COURTS WHEN I
RESIDENTS FEEL APPREHENSION OR
FEAR WHEN PARTICIPATING IN OUR-
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE OUR COLLECTIVE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS UNDERMINE.
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
. IMMIGRANT POPULATION
ESPECIALLY UNDER DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS ARE
VICTIMIZED AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE
THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFRAID TO
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PROSECUTORS TO REPORT THAT
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY NOT ONLY DOES
IT. ALLOW THE PERPETRATOR OF
THAT SPECIFIC CRIME TO GO
UNPUNISHED BUT IT PUTS THAT
COMMUNITY THE EVENGREATER RISK
OF VICTIMIZATION. THIS ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY UNDER THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION. I AM A VERY
PUBLIC ISSUE I CAN TELL YOU IN
MY EXPERIENCE FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
PROSECUTING CASES- I HAD
WITNESSED ATTORNEYS
UNNECESSARILY ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT WITNESSES IMMIGRATION
STATUS IN AN ATTEMPT TO DISSUADE
THEM FROM TESTIFYING IN COURT.
IT COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE TO
DO SO LIKE I SAY. ANYTHING THAT
CREATES MORE FEAR IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES DECREASES THEIR
COOPERATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND INCREASES VICTIMIZATION
THAT'S WHY OUR OFFICE- IS
SUPPORTING AND SPONSORING CO
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION AND
AS THE SENATOR STATED. THE
LEGISLATION AS WELL CRAFTED IT
DOES ALLOW FOR THE USE OF
QUESTIONING. ABOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS WHEN IT'S RELEVANT- AND
ALSO TO POINT OUT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE LEGISLATION
PROHIBITS A PERSON OR THEIR
ATTORNEY FROM VOLUNTARILY
DISCLOSING THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS- TO THE COURT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO RE
ENACT THIS LEGISLATION AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. I CAN TELL
YOU ANECDOTALLY. RESIDENTS OF
THIS STATUTE WHILE IT WAS IN
EFFECT A LIEU VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATING ANY. USE OF THE
UNNECESSARY QUESTIONING ABOUT A
VICTIM OR WITNESSES IMMIGRATION
AND CRIMINAL COURTS SO JUST THE
MERE PRESENCE OF THIS ON THE
STATUTES WILL. SERVE ITS
INTENDED PURPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT UP IS MERCER DIAZ.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAY
THIRTIETH AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
LEGAL AID AT WORK A NONPROFIT
LEGAL ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATES FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
RATE OF LOW WAGE WORKERS. I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY THE CO
SPONSOR AND TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
THIRTY SIX. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WIENER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. SB EIGHT THIRTY SIX EIGHT
THIRTY SIX WILL INSURE
IMMIGRATION STATUS INFORMATION
CANNOT BE USED AS A TOOL OF
INTIMIDATION THAT WOULD TELL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR THE
MILLIONS OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S HOME AS THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEALS HAS
RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA LAWS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS QUOTE LEAVE
NO ROOM FOR DOUBT ABOUT THE
STATE'S PUBLIC POLICY WITH
REGARD. TO THE IRRELEVANCE OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AN
ENFORCEMENT OF THE STATE LABOR
EMPLOYMENT AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER LARGE SH DESPITE THE
RELEVANT THE MIGRATION STATUS TO
EMPLOYERS LIABILITY UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT LINE
INCLUDES TWO OCT IN A TIME TO
DISCOVER AND DISCLOSE THE STATUS
THROUGH THE LITIGATION PROCESS
AS A WAY TO TURN WORKERS FROM
ASSERTING THEIR RIGHT. FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN A CASE THAT WAS
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF AN
IMMIGRANT WORKER WHO HAD WORKED
FOR YOUR EMPLOYER FOR MORE THAN
TEN YEARS ONLY TO BE TERMINATED
DAYS AFTER EXERCISING. HIS
WORKERS COMPENSATION RIGHT.
DURING THE READING IT INTEREST
ANY RELEVANT IMMIGRATION STATUS
. I RECOGNIZE BERMAN CIRCUIT
THESE TYPES OF INCREASE ALLOWING
PLAYERS TO REYES IMPLICITLY THE
THREAT OF DEPORTATION AND
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION EVERY TIME
A WORKER WHETHER DOCUMENTED OR
UNDOCUMENTED FILED AN EMPLOYMENT
ACTION. THIS IS THE SAME PER
DISCLOSURE THAT THE STATUS IN
OPEN COURT IN EITHER INCIDENT
THAT CAUSES COUNTLESS ACTS OF
ILLEGAL AND REPREHENSIBLE
CONDUCT TO GO AND REPORTED TO
ROADS STANDARDS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA WORKERS SHOULD BE
ABLE RESPECTFUL ENSURE THAT
WORKERS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS CAN ACCESS
OUR COURT. IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FOR THE ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT AND CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS
SH BECAUSE OF THIS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AIBO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO THE ROOM
FORTY TWO OLD THREE IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE
SIX. SEEN ON ONE HERE MODERATE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES OR
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN Q. WISHING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT THREE SIX. IF YOU ARE AN
OF S. EIGHT THREE SIX SIX ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
ONE SIXTY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- BR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE SIX
. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN ON THAT
. NATIONAL INSPIRON BEHALF OF
THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE BY NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE- LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LEVINE NUMBER NINETEEN
Hí
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CAN MEMBERS THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG CALLING ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND PRIVACY IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT THREE SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS THIS IS
GREGORY FIDEL ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JOSEPH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WE
HAVE A LINE A NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
CAN WEIGHING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF SB EIGHT THIRTY SIX
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
THREE. I NUMBER FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BROUGHT BRING
COMMITTEE BOARD MEMBER JOHNNY
CANNELLA THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA
THEY CRIED CO SPONSOR OF SB
EIGHT THIRTY SIX WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYMORE IN THE QUEUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD. WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
LISTED. IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. EIGHT THREE SIX HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO ALL THREE. HEARING
SEEN NONE MODERATE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND AFTER
WITNESSES QUEUED UP WILL TAKE
HER TESTIMONY NOW- APPEAR IN
OPPOSITION OF AT EIGHT THIRTY
THANK. ONE OF THEM VERO. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY PARTICULAR GOVERNOR
CIRCA OKAY I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE HAS OR ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS RELATES
TO. SB EIGHT THREE SIX. IN
CHINA- MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATORS SKINNER- SOONER WHEN
WE SELECT CLOSE WITH RESPECT
ESPERANDO OKAY WE HAVE A DUE
PASSI JUDICIARY- CHILTON PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SB. EIGHT THREE
SIX THREE EIGHT THREE SIX TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD DIETRO VOGUE VOTING
TROUBLED NOT VOTING COM LONGER I
COME LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WIENER WIENER I'D FOUR ZERO.
GET THAT MEASURES OUT FOUR ZERO
CONGRADULATIONS AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENT IS SOMEONE I
THINK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COME- COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE- PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY OUR AUTHORS AND
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE ON MARCH
EIGHTH WE STAND ADJOURNED.